a battle between interdimensional
entities and giving birth to a bouncing
bundle of Terror get ready to dig into
all the Gory details surrounding the
ending of terrifier 2. but where
spoilers ahead the miles County Massacre
is a name given to the event of the
first terrifier movie in the universe of
Terror fire 2. there are frequent
references to this event throughout the
sequel which takes place exactly one
year after that event as Jonathan has
developed an obsession with the killings
you think that guy's still out there
what's up with you and this clown all of
a sudden you're like obsessed they never
found his body but it's not just
Jonathan there's a broader cultural
interest in the events as well a talk
show hosts interviews the sole survivor
of the original bloodbath Victoria Hayes
and their significant news coverage of
the event marking his anniversary on TV
online and in the newspapers terrifier 2
largely stands on its own narratively
and viewers don't need to have seen the
first film to understand what the miles
County Massacre was it also helps the
attention paid to the miles County
massacre in terrifier 2 is ultimately
more thematically important than
narratively
[Applause]
oh the clown made his first appearance
in Damien Leone's 2011 short film
terrifier where the character was played
by Mike Gianelli that shot that became a
segment in Leone's first feature the
Anthology movie All Hallows Eve Bert's
already in all hollow's Eve it seems
that ours isn't just a man dressed in
clown makeup as he makes his entrance
Vera TV set as a character's watch an
evil VHS tape David Howard Thornton took
over the role when art at the spotlight
for 2013's terrifier which ends with odd
seemingly dead from a self-inflicted
gunshot wound before his body disappears
from a morgue terrifier 2 pushes things
even further as it reintroduces us who
still has a gaping head wound but is
otherwise fine there's no real
explanation given for how the clown
survived but as the sequel goes on we
get some hints it seems that art might
be a cosmic or Supernatural entity in
the same way that some fans believe
Michael Myers from Halloween is simply
the embodiment of metaphysical evil as
we learn more about Sienna father's
visions and terrifier too there's some
evidence that art is far more than a
human in a clown outfit and is instead
something mythical that would explain
why he can pass into reality through
media and why he seems to be unkillable
but it doesn't quite explain his
particular Glee in the horrific violence
he commits that remains disturbingly
inexplicable
Sierra is a high schooler struggling
with a recent loss of her father to
Suicide while attempting to maintain
good relationships with her brother
Jonathan and their mom Barbara when we
meet her she's making a Halloween
costume based on the Fantasy character
that her dad an artist created for her
along with creating the Fantasy
character for Sienna Haddad also gave
her a sword that seems to hold mystical
powers and is one of the only weapons
that can defend against Art's evil and
cause significant damage to the clown
from everything we can see she's just a
regular teenager living through the ups
and downs of life but in a dream
sequence early in terrifier 2 we can see
that there's something special about her
when her dream has an effect on reality
and starts a fire as the movie goes on
Siena becomes Art's Target while
Jonathan furthers his investigations
into the connection their father had to
Art and eventually he theorizes that
Sienna is the only one who can truly
defeat the clown her importance only
becomes clearer when she confronts us at
the end of the movie and even manages to
come back from the dead we can't say for
sure whether Sienna is the same kind of
cosmic or Supernatural entity as art or
whether she is simply capable of
channeling the Timeless being that her
father discovered and said he created
for her either way we can say for sure
that she's a great final girl and
there's certainly something magical
about her
terrifier 2 introduce his audiences to a
character that's never named but
credited as the little pale girl early
on in the film when art visits a
laundromat to clean up after murdering
The Unlucky coroner who wants to inspect
his body the girl appears in the
laundromats and shoots him a wide creepy
clown smile she then approaches art and
engages him in a silent game of Patty
Cake it's the bizarre moments that
raises a lot of questions one of which
is quickly answered at least partially
we get to see that from the point of
view of the only other person in the
laundromat artists playing putty cake
with the air it seems that the little
pale girl may simply be a vision of Arts
but Sienna and her brother Jonathan can
see her as well the reason Sienna and
Jonathan can see her and others can't is
undoubtedly due to the strange Ling that
they have with art that we'll talk about
a little more in a moment after first
seeing the little pale girl Jonathan
does some research and discovers that
she looks exactly like a girl who is
believed to have been Art's first victim
it's possible then that this girl's Soul
has somehow been transformed and bound
to us in a way that has made her his
attendant allowing her to keep him
company as he terrorizes people but she
isn't simply a passive Observer instead
she takes an active role in arts to
various schemes as we see when she
mimics Jonathan's voice in a call to
Sienna oh [__] he seems to suspect
something isn't quite right about the
phone call I
am giving us a reason to ponder what's a
possible supernatural abilities might be
while we can't save a certain what the
connection is between art and Sienna we
have some ideas at first when Jonathan
shows Sienna that their dad had drawn
art and was collecting newspaper
clippings about his killings it seems
possible that perhaps their father is
Art either he faked his death to become
this terrain's killer or he somehow
became the host of a metaphysical evil
and hasn't entirely lost his connection
to his human life but as the movie goes
on the former seems impossible given
what we learn about his death the latter
though seems like it may still be true
and that leads to our two theories about
what exactly the connection may be the
first is that her father's tumor caused
him to see beyond human reality and see
two warring Eternal entities one evil
and one good this would then allow for
the possibility that the evil entity has
somehow taken over her father's Essence
the other is that her dad somehow
brought out to life from his own psyche
through the power of His well art this
would also explain why he was able to
create a character for his daughter and
a weapon that can stand against the
Clown
Sienna's dream sequence near the start
of terrifier 2 may be one of the longest
dream sequences in any horror movie she
dreams of a strange children's TV show
set where a woman sings A jaunty song
about a clown Cafe young people hang out
on a small playset and a line of adults
has Cuda but a food truck a food truck
with Art's face on it nearby a young boy
is filming a Serial commercial for an
art themed cereal that includes roaches
and razor blades we see the boy choose
some of the disgusting cereal and bleed
from the mouth before reaching into the
box for a surprise suddenly art appears
and kills everyone on set he uses
increasingly wild weapons like a big
machine gun and a flamethrower to
devastate the sets and all the people on
them it seems like it's just a
horrifying dream but when Sienna
deflects a fire from Art's flamethrower
with her father's sword she causes a
real fire to appear in her bedroom and
later in the movie when she's stabbed by
art with the same sword she falls into a
tank of water on the set that she saw in
Her Dream but now everyone is dead and
mutilated we can't be sure whether
siena's dream was a glimpse of something
that happened in the real world but it
was certainly More Than Just A Dream
after art stops Sienna with the sword
her father gave her she falls through a
hole in the terrifier ride at the
carnival where Artis Lord her but she
doesn't just fall into dirt to another
level of concrete she falls into a water
tank on the edge of the scene from a
dream more than being confined to a
water tongue that's drowning her she's
also being held down by something that
looks equally like a frayed rope a worm
and a decomposing human hand again it
seems possible that this is her seeing
something of Art's world that he has
transported her here by killing her with
the mystical weapon bestowed upon her by
her father but she refuses to accept
defeat she struggles to get loose and
while she isn't able to succeed at first
she is finally able to break free and
heal herself through what seems to be a
sheer force of will motivated by her
love for her brother she thinks of
Jonathan and how she wants to keep him
safe from art and the saw begins to Glow
along with her stomach wound the wound
then begins to heal and she can Break
Free of whatever is holding her in the
tank before returning to the land of the
living and decapitating art to say The
Power of Love brought her back may sound
cheesy but it also seems true she was
unwilling to allow her brother to die
horribly at the hands of the sadistic
clown and that power allowed her to will
herself Back to Life as we know it well
the first Terror fire clocks in under 90
minutes and overwhelmingly focuses on
delivering extremely disturbing horror
sequences for the duration of its run
time terrifier 2 is a heftier film at a
full 2 hours and 18 minutes and while
some might have been interested in a
pure slasher that lasts so long Leone
has practiced sequels full of subtler
thematic exploration first and foremost
are the themes of grief trauma and
mental illness as Sienna Jonathan and
Barbara are still reeling from the death
of their beloved father and husband the
movie spends time with them as they talk
about their loss and the different ways
that they have responded to it and
whether those coping mechanisms are
healthy but the movie is also interested
in how the media fixate sun and often
exploits real-life tragedies their
significant time spent showing different
kinds of news coverage of Arts murders
and especially the attention paid to how
poorly Victoria is treated by the talk
show host after her interview
yeah well if you think she looks stupid
on television imagine what she looks
like sitting two feet away from you
there's gonna gag at one point
most abstractly but perhaps most
fascinatingly terrifier 2 seems to be
asking questions about horror movies and
what we want from them artists
constantly mugging for the camera waving
his hands smiling and laughing at the
horrific violence he enacts essentially
inviting the audience to enjoy his
cruelty with him but the violence in the
movie is so intense and so realistically
rendered that it'll likely be impossible
for most viewers to experience these as
fun kills in a slasher
are you not entertained
the mid-credits scene of terrifier 2
doesn't involve Sienna or her family and
instead we sent us on Victoria Hayes who
has been confined to a mental hospital
after she attacks the talk show host who
insulted her at first we only see two
members of the staff at the hospital
talking about her and how she's being
remarkably calm as her patient but sue
me here Victoria screaming and we see
her writing obscenities on the wall with
her blood then her stomach starts to
swell and it rapidly grows until she
gives birth to Arts somehow living ahead
it's a wild sequence that is nearly
impossible to make sense of but our
understanding is that Victoria has
become linked to Art in a similar way
that the little pale girl has only
Victoria is still living the fact that
Victoria is still alive May mean that
she is now Art's Lifeline to our world
he's been defeated by Sienna and a
mystical sword but can return through
Victoria
if you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please call the
National Suicide Prevention Lifeline by
dialing 988 or by calling
1-800-273-talk 8255
[Music]